...if it works it's going to shed
some light on one of the biggest mysteries
in sensory science. Which is we're
going to see if I can taste fat.
Not bacon. Not cream. Fat.
Specifically this fat. This is linoleic acid. This is
an omega-6 polyunsaturated fatty acid.
And taste researchers who are
investigating this think there are
pretty good reasons why humans should
be able to taste fat. So it's essential
to our food supply. It's used by the brain.
It's used by the immune system.
They say there's a good reason why your body
should be able to pick it out in its environment.
Scientists currently divide taste into 5 basics
or primaries. These will look very
familiar to you, I'm sure. Salty, sweet, bitter,
umami (also known as savory) and sour.
These are considered the building blocks
of taste. Things that you cannot
break apart, you cannot subdivide. Just the way
on the color wheel blue or red are
considered primaries or basics.
A scientist said to me you cannot
subdivide sweet. Sweetness is a thing
unto itself. But some of you
might remember, those of you who like
me went to school in the last century,
remember a time when there was only 4 (basic tastes).
So this idea of umami or savory
only made the list in the year 02000.
For people who are still like "what is that?"
it's usually the flavor that's
associated with things
very savory things: like Parmesan cheese,
caramelized onions, a slow cooked tomato paste...
would be considered umami. So that's in
the United States. This concept was
actually named in 01908 in Japan
by a scientist named Dr. Kakunai Akita
who said it is a fifth taste. And its
associated with the amino acid glutamate.
Just the way sugar is associated
with sweet. Salt with salt. He says
glutamate is what's responsible for [umami].
When this was accepted in the western
world around the year 02000, it kind of
upended the taste research world.
If there were five now, why not 6?
Why not 7? Why not 1000? It's kind of like
where we are right now with taste research is
where astronomy was at the end of the 17th century
when astronomers were like, oh, okay Jupiter
what if there's something out beyond
Jupiter? What if our system is
bigger than we thought it was? So fat
is championed by Dr. Rick Mattes who's
a nutrition scientist at Purdue University.
And what's weird is there is actually
no list of what you have to do to
be considered a basic taste. So he made one
which people like. So here's the basic idea.
First of all: has to be a receptor
for it on the tongue. There has to be
something that locks with a certain
molecule. And they believe there are 2
for fatty acids. They are called CD36 and GPR120.
Okay: nerves. It has to get to the
brain along the right nervous pathway.
It has to go along the gustatory nerve.
So this is tricky because your mouth also
has nerves in it (bumps mic) Oops, pardon me.
Your mouth also has nerves in it for touch.
When it comes to food this is what we
call mouth feel, right? That things feel
creamy or they feel crunchy or whatever.
So people sometimes say, why isn't
spicy a basic taste? Or why isn't cool a basic taste?
It's because that's actually touch.
It's a feeling it's actually pain in
the case of spiciness. Okay, it has to have
a purpose. I know I wrote that in yellow,
so nobody can see it. It has to have a
purpose. And the idea is... not...
not everybody agrees with this. But
usually they'll say okay basic tastes are either
attractive or aversive. So the idea with
sweet is it's attractive. It shows you where
the calories are. So you want to eat it.
The idea with umami is that it
shows you where the protein is. What
amino acids are in. So that's good to  eat it.
Bitter things are usually poisonous,
toxic, so don't eat it. With salt and with
sourness people disagree, but they think
it's either a matter of concentration or
satiety. In other words you like a little
bit, but you don't like a lot. Or you like
it when you your body needs it, and then
you reject it when it's too much.
Must have a physiological reaction
this one's a little bit trickier. Mattes says
your body has to do something
in reaction to it with fat. A lot of fats
are these giant blocks called
triglycerides. Mattes says there is
a salivary enzyme that called lipase that
basically chips free fatty acids
off this big block That's what can lock into
the receptors on your tongue.
They know that mice make this enzyme. And
they can taste that because when they
block it might stop preferring the fat.
But do humans have it? And so
in his human experiments
what he does is he makes people chew
hard fats like coconut and soft fats like olive oil.
And then he measures how much lipase
they produce. So chew the hard fat,
you salivate more, you get more of this lipase
that he says is the physiological reaction.
Here's the thing we care about: can anybody
actually sense the darn thing?
And can they actually distinguish it
from the other five that we have?
So that's why I went to the museum.